hello and welcome to the introductory
lesson of the certified Android app
developer course offered by simply
learned in this lesson you will get an
overview of the course so what is
Android Android is a mobile operating
system developed by Google based on the
Linux kernel and is primarily designed
for touchscreen based mobile devices
like smartphones and tablets Android
apps that extend the device
functionality are created using Android
software development kit and often with
a java programming language that can
access Android API s interesting facts
about Android Android was first designed
for cameras later it was implemented for
mobile phones when compared with other
operating systems the Android OS has
been updated an incredible number of
times resulting in a web-based service
which is remarkably different than the
original version of this mobile
operating system it is unlocked a number
of new paths Android studio is now the
default integrated development
environment IDE in short supported by
Google to develop Android applications
we will learn how to install the Android
SDK in Android studio which provide an
essential environment to build an
Android application in fundamentals like
activities fragments and UI controls to
name a few why Android with the highest
market share Android is the dominant
mobile operating system today it's
running on countless models of
smartphones tablets and other devices
what's even more important is the fact
that the whole Android ecosystem
underwent many improvements we got new
gadgets like smartwatches new software
like Gradle android studio and androids
new OS which is the 6.0 marshmallow
Android today be it a washing machine or
a quadcopter Android has become integral
to everyday living in more ways than you
can count over 1 billion Android devices
have been activated Android rules the
smartphone market enjoying 85% market
share smartphones have changed our lives
and how today people can barely recall
life before mobile apps from checking
the weather the minute you wake up
defining a recipe for pot roast from
getting a doctor on demand to playing a
game while waiting for the bus apps have
become a way of life key advantages of
Android firstly marketshare ID sees
research shows that Android led the pack
with 78% market share in terms of the
number of smartphone shipped worldwide
in the first three months of 2015
Android studio is an IDE or integrated
development environment designed and
developed specifically for Android app
development within seconds amazingly
fast and efficient Android studio can
help set up new Android projects for
various kinds of Android apps
applications deployed to the Google Play
Store are available for download by
users within a few hours compared to a
few weeks for Apple's App Store Android
developers or more because of high
number of users in Android OS many
companies are investing huge amounts of
money on Android application development
this is where open access and open
source principles have shown their true
potentials Google's Android has grown
immensely from October 2003 when Rubin
miner Sears and white started Android
Inc in California the popularity of
Android didn't come about in a day
Android developers braved buggy ide s OS
fragmentation slow emulators and boring
user interface to what it is today
Linux based open-source Android has
boosted the fast growing smartphone
market world over it released the first
version on the HTC dream phone in 2008
it took several iterations over the
years to get it to what it is today in
the last couple of years the Android
ecosystem has seen many improvements in
terms of new software hardware and OS
what next ask Google the developers the
makers of devices now that the OS is
stable where do we go from here Android
which was started with smartphones is
now in smartwatches TVs and cars it is
proven that it can be run on every
gadget which has a small microprocessor
as the trend continues the number of
apps available in the Google Play Store
crossed
1.6 million as per July 2015 stats which
clearly shows is market penetration most
people like to use Android technology in
their smartphones because of its obvious
advantages with it's unbelievable
popularity developers will certainly
want to get into Android application
development to a greater extent and get
the best from the booming app industry
the biggest advantage of Android is that
it is an open-source integrated software
platform it decreases the development
phase and offers simple to apply
development tools it is encouraged
innovation among the developers such as
new applications to help sustain in a
highly competitive market its
association with Google has made it
powerful with Google Maps and Google
Voice apps in today's business context
with Android available as an open
platform customization has become far
less expensive than other platforms this
course is intended for people who want
to create native applications on Android
it is necessary that you have a good
understanding of Java before getting
started on this path if you don't know
Java there's no need to worry as simply
learn provides an introductory Java
essentials course along with this to get
you comfortable with the basics of Java
required for Android application
development Android architecture has
four layers each layer has its own set
of libraries and we will be talking
about each layer and its functionality
we will also clarify the dynamics to
understand the core libraries and talk
more about the Android OS for app
development we will explore the building
blocks of Android applications like
activity services content providers
broadcastreceiver and intense we will
also explore the use of advanced Android
ap is related to wireless connection of
devices network connectivity battery
optimization syncing to cloud and
Android wear app development we will go
through the best practices do's and
don'ts while developing Android
application to publish on your Play
Store
this course will help you to set up the
Android environment and understand its
architecture followed by information on
the basic concepts required to build
simple Android apps you will go through
the Android user interfaces activities
controls layouts services and content
providers along with location and
multimedia api's after successfully
establishing the footprint on Android
basics by developing a few well-known
apps the course will move to advanced
concepts like wireless connectivity
syncing to cloud Android wear app
development google play to distribute
and monetize and many more at the end of
the course you will have hands-on
training and developing for top rated
apps you will also need to complete the
assigned project by using the concepts
learned throughout the course the
purpose of the project is to make you
confident and get the skills required to
develop any Android application that you
want so are you excited to know what all
you get access to with the Android
application developer course there are a
host of features made available to you
you get 30 hours of instructor led
training and access to 25 hours of high
quality eLearning there are 2 projects
with 30 hours of training that you will
be working on in addition to 4 apps to
be developed within the course to help
you understand the concepts of Android
along with on-demand support to take
care of any queries that you may have to
test your understanding of the concepts
covered we give you chapter and quizzes
you will also learn how to develop
popular apps like location-based
notification app and Android wear
activity monitor app that makes your
learning more exciting we also provide
you with a downloadable ebook what's
more you get the Java essentials course
within the Android course for free once
you complete the course successfully we
award you a certificate in Android
application development showcasing your
skill set in developing Android app
project submission and certification for
the Android app developer certification
it is mandatory to fulfill the following
criteria complete the two projects
provided by simply learn within the
online self learning course access
period screenshots are the final output
and the source code used should be made
the project submission is simply learned
comm within the online self learning
course access period the completed
project will be evaluated by the lead
trainer for any queries or difficulties
while solving projects you can
persistence as from our on-demand
support team if you have subscribed to
the live virtual classroom training you
may attend any ongoing batch of the
Android app developer course for
assistance if you face any issues while
implementing the project note it is
mandatory that you fulfill this criteria
to become a certified Android
application developer from simply learn
on-demand support more on out on demand
support it comprises experts for
resolving any queries while pursuing the
Android application developer course
want to submit a query through on demand
support it's simple just visit
www.whitakerbrothers.com